welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
speaker nancy pelosi's hypocrisy is on
full display once again
as she continues to enforce the mask
mandate in the house
even though there's not one in the
senate or at the white house
here's pelosi at a white house event
yesterday where she was seen mingling
with
colleagues and cabinet secretaries
without a mask in sight
meanwhile she had the audacity to slap
four members of congress
including wounded veteran brian mast
with a 500
fine for failing to adhere to her
anti-science mandate
here's a video of mass being reprimanded
by
a staffer for the for the house sergeant
of arms
during a debate on the house floor
tuesday congressman mast earned
a bronze star and the purple heart he
lost
both of his legs in afghanistan as a
bomb disposal expert
and now they're going to find him 500
for not wearing a mask just
unbelievable joining us now with
reaction is one of mass
colleagues north carolina congressman
madison cawthorne
and fox news legal analyst greg jarrett
uh gentlemen thank you so much for
joining here uh
with us uh congressman i want to start
with you because you've taken a strong
stance saying hey i don't need to wear a
mask on the floor of the house
uh why what what's the principle here
and are you gonna win that fight
well i don't know if we're gonna win i'm
sure she'll try and find us but if nancy
pelosi wants to find us then
absolutely let her do her worst i
believe that patriotic americans have
our back and so i'm willing to take a
stand
i'm not sure if you saw the video but
there's a young 10 year old boy who was
basically
reprimanding a school board out at for
his school because he was having to wear
a mask
and if he has the courage to stand up
and do what this nation's leaders
is not then that made me emboldened i
mean imagine george washington
facing down the british at yorktown but
imagine him wearing a mask
we're not descended from fearful men and
so if you're only afraid
to wear a mask because you are afraid
that nancy pelosi is going to find you
stand up be an american man and woman
have some courage
yeah now greg i i think there's an
interesting legal question because you
and i were talking earlier but
i don't know if they have the
constitutional ability to actually
impose a fine on members of congress
well i think you're right about that
jason i mean first of all there is no
federal law that empowers mass
mandates period state and local
governments have some limited health and
safety powers but
not the feds and pelosi readily admits
she can't force people to get vaccinated
she can't even force members to disclose
if they've been vaccinated so
she's already on shaky legal ground but
she really jason crossed the line
when she began to dock the pay
of members who refuse to wear a mask
some of which
have been vaccinated or following cdc
guidelines
why did she cross the legal line it's
arguably a violation of the 27th
amendment which says
in effect you cannot alter the pay of
members of congress without first an
intervening general election and that
hasn't happened look the point is
pelosi can enact all kinds of rules of
conduct for its
members of the house but the punishment
is restricted to things like censure and
reprimand
uh even expulsion or restitution what
she
cannot do is trifle with the paychecks
of members what's to stop her from
weaponizing
paychecks to force a particular vote
that would be extortion or
bribery and certainly government
corruption
you know and this makes no sense in so
many ways
as i mentioned some of the people have
already been vaccinated
they have lifted the masked rules of the
white house in the u.s
senate but pelosi refuses to lift it in
the house of representatives because
she's all about extremes this isn't
about
science it's about her thirst for power
and control
she's addicted to telling people what to
do how to think
and how to behave not to mention the
fact that she's been
she's a hypocrite having been caught
violating mask
rules locally in san francisco
yeah congressman this is a bit of
theater right i mean
the cameras are focused on the floor of
the house of representatives
but this mask mandate isn't in force in
your office or in the halls or in
committee hearings correct
no it's not enforced there at all i mean
you'll oftentimes see democrat members
of congress
who are wearing no masks in the elevator
but then as soon as we get to the second
floor of the
uh of the building they then put their
masks on because they know they're about
to be on c-span
it's all political theater and i think
jared is absolutely correct
the democrats are addicted to power they
saw how much power they could gain
through fear
and now they're desperate to keep
holding on to that
yeah watch this uh this is uh senator
murphy going to the floor of the united
states senate where there is not a mass
mandate
but if you watch there he kind of goes
he puts on the mask
then he's going to vote and so then he
takes it off
i mean it's just a show it's not like he
really believes it
but i i think greg there is a bigger
broader principle here and that is one
of personal responsibility
and personal freedom correct
it is and look one of the great myths to
emerge from the pandemic
is that government officials can
prohibit you
from doing what the constitution
guarantees you
have a right to do you have a right to
go to
work uh you have a right to uh go to the
local church you have a right to shop
for food
um and you know you have a right to
assemble
in places uh like outdoor theaters in
indoors
in places like the house chamber without
nancy pelosi
punishing you by docking your pay which
he's doing
is rank lawlessness
congressman i want to give you the last
word but what's your take on personal
responsibility
and and the idea that you get to make
and have the self-determination yourself
well jason those two words you just use
self-determination
that really embodies what it truly means
to be a conservative
i believe we're all royalty in the
united states of america that's your
apartment your house where you live
that is your castle you make the rules
we don't make decrees for you in
washington dc and so
to my other colleagues you know if you
want to wear a mask on the house floor
go ahead and do it but don't you dare
reprimand me when i don't have one on
and if you're only afraid to wear a mask
because of nancy pelosi's fine
then when we come back in session on
june 14th take the mask off
she's just a puppet
thank you thank you congressman thank
you for your service and greg jarrett
thank you for joining us as well
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else